drilhon golly à la citrouille raviot
l'oni fromage oka fumée jiras solide
basilic et parmigiano reggiano bienvenue
dans un monde en pleine ébullition
celui des pâtes farcies on est rendu
plus loin qu'on était ya pas si
longtemps en terme de goût au québec et
non seulement au niveau du goût mais
aussi au niveau de la liste
d'ingrédients de l'authenticité est
d'avoir un produit qui soit le plus près
possible de celui préparé à la maison
preuve de l'engouement pour les pâtes
farcies provigo et l'autre gros joueurs
de l'industrie offre désormais des
produits davantage gastronomie les gens
cherchent de plus en plus des solutions
rapides fini travailler 5 heures et
demie 6 heures qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
prendre pied rapide qui se mange bien
quand vous avez choisi toutes ses
saveurs particulières on est allé coûte
déjà savoir ce qu'ils aiment mais aussi
à l'affût des tendances comme par
exemple nos cappellacci betteraves et
fromages de chèvres sont destinés à des
gens qui veulent peut-être une perte
plus de samedi soir est bonne à mardi
quand même mais on se permet d'aller un
peu plus loin au niveau de leur audace
moi j'étais là première surprise d'avoir
une histoire de fromage il vient donc
plus facile
chou fleur
quant à anthony qu'il crut la
nutritionniste
m crépeau a analysé une trentaine de ces
produits réfrigérés dont les prix
varient entre 1 $ 20 et 3 dollars vers
les 100 grammes
sa venue en force signé avec truffe je
sais haut de gamme
thomas terlouw mais burrata matin la
sesto de terre on voit toutes les
gouttes et moi je te vois pas douter
[Musique]
attardons-nous d'abord à la liste des
ingrédients télésouffleur 10.00
schappler et ensuite les fleurs vie un
troisième et un non moins intéressants
versus par exemple celui ci a abritera
du fromage de chèvre les ingrédients si
vraiment betteraves fromage de chèvre
fromage ricotta
donc c'est toujours intéressant vraiment
d'aller valider avec les ingrédients
pour est certain la majorité des
produits analysés propose une portion de
référence de 100 gr
c'est un grain est ce que c'est
suffisant fort possible que les gens
mangent une fois unis seraient même deux
fois c'est donc là faut faire attention
voire intuitive le doublé petit rappel
libéral c'est toujours d'avoir le tiers
ou la moitié de la recette de légumes
donc ce que si je fais ça à mon avis tu
as l'air beaucoup plus rempli plus
satisfaisante
est ce que les produits contient
suffisamment de protéines non il y en a
aucun qui dépassait les 15 g de
protéines qu'on veut minimalement par
repas c'est ce qui est bon il va voir
vraiment une saison peut rager du
fromage des fois avec c'est donc je
pense aussi des protéines ailleurs ceux
qui se démarquent vraiment c'était la
gamme au soleil ou c'est elle qui va le
plus ou apports en protéines dans leurs
produits
au terme de femmes c'est assez varié
vraiment savoir combien de poulet dans
un avion dit comme ça pas beaucoup il
n'y a que 14 % de farce dans ces mini
raviolis au sol et millau pour cela il
fallait vraiment que la balance soit
précise le chef enseignant igor brotto
et trois étudiants de l'institut de
tourisme et d'hôtellerie du québec ont
calculé des ratios pas farce d'une
douzaine de produits parmi les 30 que
nous avons analysé le ratio de la
plupart des produits est autour de 60%
de pâtes et 40% de farce plus les pâtes
sont petites et replié moins ils
contiennent de face
alors c'est l'heure de la dégustation
goûter vous le prosciutto la salle est
évidemment j'allais dire la bête noire
mais c'est la bête blanche des produits
industriels c'est toujours le sodium
comment se comportent nos amis n'est pas
de faire si c'est le cas de ces produits
berteigne plus de 600 mg par portion qui
trop et c'est sans compter le sel ajouté
dans l'eau de cuisson
ce qui embête 200 mg c'est très bon
produit chez free zone et comme ça je
vous en passer la texture est bonne au
niveau du pont s'habille fromage
parmesan
l'apparent grand général encore une fois
dans ce qu avait plus de 10 grammes mais
on avait certains essaient collection
noire certains soulignent au sapin
bertani certain olivier donc encore là
chaque gamme va voir son produit qui est
un peu plus riches en gras il ya
certains produits qui avait jusqu'à 8
grammes de gras saturés puis c'est
souvent on essaie de réduire ça embête
un gramme
je trouve qu'il y avait des produits
vraiment surprenant certains produits au
niveau de la finesse la délicatesse en
bouche la texture en bouche est très
intéressant par contre la consistance la
texture des farces
c'est là qu'il y en avait qui étaient
pas mal bien avec était trop pâteuse à
mon goût trop collant d'outreau dans ce
jeu les goûts et présente je pourrais
pas de vue sa goutte ni la mascarpone ni
la courge c'est plus une sensation
partagée est ce que vous avez senti que
c'est fait par des machines
certaines oui d'autres et avait quand
même une délicatesse qui pourrait se
rapprocher en produite et artisanal
noter que olivieri et o sole mio offre
des pâtes fraîches préparer en ontario
et au québec alors que bertani et le
choix du président vente des pâtes
importées d'italie
fraîchement décongelé
ces partis sont surgelés directement en
italie on les achemine ici au canada qui
nous ici en magasin on les décongèle et
sont vendus french montrer que c'est
commun un gage de qualité dans la tête
des gens savent italie c'est vraiment
dur en terme de show laquelle on dit la
soli mozzarella de bufflonne alors c'est
quoi le verdict selon moi si ce qui fait
sens le mieux bien née saisonnièrement
[Musique]
je vous dirais qu'un général
c'était vraiment pas mal il y en a trois
qui vont souffler qui m'ont surpris je
me disais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un bon produit sans le savoir nos
buteurs ont préféré les pattes qui sont
parmi les plus grasses et les plus à
l'est deux produits bertani gira solide
basilic et parmigiano reggiano mais des
élus n'est pas remédier à nos reggiano
et leur préférer pc collection noire
girassol y mozzarella de lait de
bufflonne pas du tout les mêmes choix
que ceux de notre nutritionniste en
termes de meier 26 via pc et oliveri qui
se démarque comme ayant un certain choix
qui sont vraiment meilleur
et en termes de protéines o sole mio qui
contenait la pauvreté le plus élevé de
tous les autres du
[Musique]